I'm turning the gamesound on it's a bit
too loud no turned it up I hope that's
all still recording let me just
double-check yeah uh-huh
oh this is hardly fair
this is ridiculous ha ha ha ha
I see jackass trip so fast
ah but that's the secret of the
Slenderman he will find you in your
darkest dive hours he will kill you dead
until you die of death poisoning it
sounds as if you're reading me a bedtime
story the very scary bedtime story
this map is pretty large yeah yeah I'm
gonna be able to find everything you
need ah too many trees I found another
note a few seconds ago so I'm a quarter
of the way there really I don't know I
don't think you're gonna kill me right
behind you
I'm not looking behind whoa look behind
you I do that what battery life will go
down in an old guy yeah I see you're
kind of hurting for you don't want to go
in the building yeah you don't wanna you
don't want to go you don't want to go in
and that's nice in the building you
don't want to go oh come on you didn't
want to go with the building I've
already gonna know from the middle right
okay wait you did why I put it straight
away when I spooned in the guy that's
baloney I'm gonna cut you off at the
pass maybe I'm tricking you look at said
to your left
what my raging fence no I mean you're
right there's a fence tomorrow no look
look at me
why would I look at me come on I know
okay you come on really sue I'm not
gonna whine come on how about how about
you stand still for 10 seconds we do
hide and seek and then nobody ha oh no
no no no no no no just be acknowledged
we're back to have lunch like you're
killing me I don't know how you're doing
that that is the idea I have killing you
just hang on okay
if I die right now - ice bonuses Thunder
aah mm-hmm maybe maybe maybe I should
just turn around and look at you I'm not
back there
wait did you go haha what the hell do
you see me do [ __ ] ah no you got me
what's your fun if you want to be scared
oh that's hard that's not fair
ha ha humans are you doing my son - um
no uh-uh
well Slenderman
we meet again no wonder you got me yes
happy to see you really really yeah
really
this is how it's gonna be tonight I
would imagine you're the the zero out of
eight number in the no no that's the
computron that ami Xiao Yue yeah Sully
human
I mean Slender Man you you you don't
know
you be safe green there's no page in
here hey you said there was a pager
there there's awful that was but I think
there's 10 locations and they spot
between them like I'll stupid man this
look beautiful all the trees are red
really I like blood real ly the way she
was like an orgy blood orgy you're a
sucker Anna ah what
hey I'm right behind you are you behind
me are you really - quickly behind you
really the right deal I know all right
oh no I just know I just show you some
no it's a how are you so much faster
than me see ha ha
because I haven't gotten anything if I
never get any pages you can never tell
me oh this is ridiculous
see see the game is decide I'm gonna
help you out here let me have a look
around
alright I'll let you get a few and then
oh yeah there's a page right here mark
where I am
oh really I okay no idea where you are
look you don't know no you're next - no
look
don't know I program not done I'm not
trying to travel oh this says your
heartburn anything about its dog Scott
it's gone X and another kiss and a
hooker no come back here no I wasn't
lying you knowingly took your first note
I miss right there
so do I find be like that I will they
know whoa but it's very lonely being in
these woods every night by myself and I
just wanted a friend
oh poor slay me but no one gives an ass
slider it can go diet a corner Hut well
blow it out while I let go on your neck
you know that that loud heavy breathing
no yeah
I'll actually no it's not me I don't
even have a mouth that's like I've been
a bit of a mouth breather got it Oh -
Peck - no wait wait didn't get it so do
I really move folks I don't even know if
I am I don't know I caught you when I
had two pages how about did you catch me
cuz you're sliding man's been eating too
many jelly doughnuts Jesus you know what
he does with the doughnuts yeah no not
that get your mind out of the gutter
no no well he puts one doughnut on each
tentacle and then waves him around I
need some like that oh she get another
pretty smile
mm-hmm-hmm Baba II just accepts your
device turn around and weirdo which way
is around turn around
no no this is a trick do you have candy
I'm trying to help you I do I have Jam
donuts you how many wait having children
sir do you have chocolate frosted
there's no deal I like Jam Jam stupa hi
dammit the tunnel again how do I keep
getting back here huh huzzah
no but to do that I don't know but you
do that oh you let your body just for
the ground oh well I'm kind of dead oh
I'm still the Czar's arm okay are you
the Slenderman oh you know I'm human hi
where are you mark I need to we need to
stick together
ah oh yeah me okay yeah they not always
lie always out of my voice you sound
pretty much the same depth and loudness
from every direction are they follow the
sound of my voice I like I make a bird
call thighs are it I think do you hear
that yeah yeah I'm going in that
direction doing that drill we going that
way Burpo Jerry you got it whooping make
one back make one back whooping I got I
heard it Regan yeah doing it Wooper okay
got it
all right locked out dark okay okay I'm
coming baby
ah bueno fee eight wait no wait this is
a dead end wait no okay I got in here
all right coming baby I'm coming to save
you
cuz this is a horrible bike is rusty
it's old pass up I went out oh okay I
could've sworn I just saw you were in
the past really really right no no it
wasn't was it up a page I better
bathroom flutter nuns in the bathroom oh
yeah just I'll make a bird call what a
[ __ ] Herman's nearby that way you know
so you can be warned okay thank you
am i overloading my mic no it's fine
okay Oh Jake does UMaine malaika ho
hahaha
sorry the power of my voice is uh rather
for carries alright I'm in the center
hall way no way no I'm not I'm by the
horse and you can see it - penis and
balls it
his horse penis horse balls looks very
upset eating crow cuz if we make the
same one then look on another page I got
some weird shadows going on here so I
don't feel right yo are you doing with
the horse
don't walk it on you right now Oh God
Oh huh ah how's a good horse okay what
what who you saying wait were you
talking about hey what you to the boss
what no I I did I didn't do anything
I'm calling the RSPCA all right no don't
do that
if the horse later love find the horse
man I can't find a horse by the horse
follow the sounds I'm in the bathroom
Ed's good what follow the sounds oh whoa
- nothing - just stand it up it happens
every two minutes oh Jesus Christ no no
he struck me really yeah I'm onna I'm on
bread bar now Oh God
really Joey yeah he uh he caught me
behind the desk when I was spending over
looking for a note oh not know
don't don't think whatever you thinking
clear out Yamaha house drinking water
and will spit it out my toes so so
Slenderman caught you while you were
bending over a desk looking for a note
hey I'll be vanish
oh yeah how about we changed subject oh
there's gotta be some good fan art drawn
from that one oh let me tell you I'm
sort nobody in their right mind wouldn't
all right fine
everybody picture this and draw this get
ready right notes everyone it's yamimash
in a skirt like a polkadot skirt hung
over a desk like oh stop it Slendy and
flenderman like one tentacle is lifting
up the skirt and he's got little like
beet hearts going up above its head and
a kowai eyes you know the Japanese quiet
like oh then yeah ah go with that one
I'm definitely going this part I my
version of this is online
oh all right where where are you I'm
Sean just temple I don't think this map
has pages I found through you've been to
I'm two pages Joe I didn't found it I'm
by the horse not the reason we
Slenderman keeps trying to kill me
because I'm the only one with pages
right get to the horse how is the horse
it's in follow the lights the lights
okay where are you describe it there's
um I'm bytom right by the bathroom break
but stay in the bathroom I'm staying in
the bathroom it's a dead come in formula
it doesn't matter I'm coming for you
spend the man is right by the bathroom
door oh I see him yes he's Oh God ah did
I made I mean I'm here I'm here to save
you I bear to serve you your beavers
right now go around him go around him
I'm Malou stairs rode them to you
to die follow me let's finish me off
are you following me or what I'm I'm
dead you're dead he can't kill me how
are you dead I found a page the how did
you die we just got together it's hate
is it it's what you know when I picked
over that no and I bent over you just
did to it
Oh starve it Slendy star Absalom I'm
free bringing going like a hill ego I
can zoom around the map up I'll try to
die where'd it go where'd it go
um just wait he'll come on Oh welcome
two seconds okay back up
I don't know scanner these eyes it's on
your left a 1000 areas huh
oh I got you lady no I got you right
where I want you uh stuck at a height Oh
big ah B you got it you got it
and you then I'm dead Oh brilliant Wow
Oh nah nah oh no gasps whose distress
eval oh wow
now I've played as him I know how to
work around him really I just will not
look at you I won't turn around and then
you'll never you'll never be able to
catch up to me so easy game keep telling
yourself that
oh yeah yeah I will this map is gigantic
by the way they're all gigantic why I
don't know it reminds me of a game I
played a long time ago called survivors
the map was huge even long by God
oh it's gonna be fun oh it's gonna be
fun
you know I always wondered if slender
was just like one giant family boo God
and they just all look the same so it's
like a twin brother and like big boo you
keep doing this I'm really good really
good at this lady man wait hang on wait
no no wait no no stop ready go fast no
how do I crouch
you can't Crouch yes I can apparently
well I totally can I totally can't
Kurtis it's Labor bad I'll see y'all be
back
I'm bend over for me ah be bash my gosh
oh my god
should not have said yeah yeah you've
had your fun slender man
oh no look behind you know you looked
rather on corner I'm gonna kill you ha
ha ha you actually turned around burger
Bo have you got there yeah
I haven't even gotta pay you can at
least let me get one page come on no oh
no no you you're so unfair yes I know
and no you know what wanna mix and you
can't kill me you know what I'm gonna do
this
there you go try to kill me now I'm
gonna yeah oh poor you guys now I have
your dead body here oh wait no I'm not
wait oh okay are you Slendy man maybe ha
ha ha I love that voice love that voice
y'all be I'm gonna get ya you gotta get
it turn off your mic I'm getting ok yeah
that's better wait maybe my game volume
would sound don't kill me yet all right
shut up be Kenny promises whoa I love it
when you whisper in my ear yeah okay
yeah let me go find a note to bend over
for you do that oh all right here we're
behind you
okay that's great I thought I don't Oh
who's gonna win this guy
ah is are you breathing down the back of
my neck oh damn haha
there's done buddy you like that no it
isn't that cool I didn't like that
didn't see that one coming did you
I saw it coming I do it gotta happen
that's actually quite startling ah dang
no nope nope nope it's some weird yeah
oh c'mon oh the horse ha ha
you had the horse why don't you go play
with the horse for a bit give me a
second
someone I sounded like when I was doing
my thing with the horse Oh quiet but I'm
almost there no no but I went out om is
ooh yeah see can't get me to pro Oh epic
take out didn't get me I'll let you up
you can I can't move I'm slow Picabo Mac
hi that's so weird
[ __ ] a vintage comes up in white hey
how's it goin all said boom oh gosh stop
it you're every wrong yeah naughty boy
that is quite freaky I will admit that's
quite freaky I finally mastered this
it's nothing that mean that is really
freaky I know it should be me and you
but I don't think so I can't see are you
Slendy bad no I'm not I'm not either
okay if we can find each other straight
away that I'd be a plus ah screw you I'm
gone four pages come on
nope nope nope god Abaddon you get all
the pages which means the Slenderman
will kill you first
Yeah right whatever Slenderman and me
have a relationship we understand each
other well smell so doing actually
Slenderman go back way back
oh my god
just because do you want [ __ ] bet had
a little bit of a fling does not mean
that you and slightly man were meant for
each other
like we are yeah okay
we're in love Slaney men and I you
didn't girl what on a page did you
I also found no I did not I didn't find
a [ __ ]
slender man loves me this is hard this
map so big oaf a debate he keeps telling
me and you're the one with all the pages
I've only got one what do you think of
doing hey I've got one too then okay I
won okay can I have a weapon can I have
a gun yeah you know this isn't that that
woman game I played a long time ago
where you actually shooting slender man
currently yeah oh slender's woods wasn't
that it yes shot him as he elevates it
was a good one that was a good one I
liked that one
that was just fun because you got to
kill the Slenderman yeah but only
temporarily
yeah Mandar like a bunch of Slendy mins
yeah right at the end like his whole
family just huh let me kill you you
killed my paw I'm gonna get you what I
want game that I saw you play called be
the Slenderman eat it oh yeah a little
RPG maker game oh yeah you play as the
Slenderman and you're trying you're a
nice woman knocking on people's doors
asking for pages and a grab of gabov oh
yeah my camera just went out and aw
there we go ah the other page um okay
okay you're three not I got to I got to
I got to to to talk to to wait okay I
went I'm wearing a tutu no no hmm
you're wearing a tutu can that be part
of the fan art too right it has to be
even the pocus go or 2/3 can be both
can I wear two two and make a two-part
one because he has more than one
tentacle he can lift up more than one
favorite a good tennis and I like some
type of manga I got three hence why they
usually just change yes let's blood
everywhere
yeah it's amazing cuz I still haven't
seen you yeah I know I've been burning
around this whole time and no one saw my
little seeing you know that's weird
I miss you yummy I miss you too man miss
you well where are you I don't know and
now I mind the horse stay there wait for
me okay oh my light went out oh alright
we've got three with this is the best
we've done this whole session I am
actually quite surprised now I'm
wondering do we both have to get a or if
we both get four does that count as a I
don't think so I think we both have to
get eight this doesn't seem to yeah well
life's not fair
suck it up yah B oh yeah I'll tell you
to fight him yeah I found it yeah he
jumps up at me oh my god I want to take
a picture you look happy good but good
dickbags were walking around fighting
painted with dslr's right up their face
whatever it's not my bathroom there's
nothing I can get us cuz we're both
looking in the other direction I don't
oh he was right by do oh did you know
you can focus your oh he's right there
ah he's right there we're gonna finally
say who the fundamental loves mommy oh
you who ever he kills first he doesn't
look as much here ah about that I've
lost you but yeah he's gonna kill I'm
right behind you oh oh hi oh don't move
don't move I lose you
Gobbo all right here Bobo you're trying
to pull a trick on me you always do this
no I don't you try brilliant okay okay
oh he's somehow oh oh where is he he's a
nothing in the world a Oh kill me
haha he loves me more
oh he does not they say that's why he's
nice ring your text where warehouse
Lindy come in you go ahead go ahead man
we're gonna die together slender man
perfect forever together
that's a beautiful love story
mmm now it'll be a hard game yeah it's
difficult I don't think we could ever
get more than three but no you know okay
that should be enough for now yeah I
enjoyed that out brave I'm okay thank
you Matt no thank you Yami mittai
I got nothing else to say so uh-oh
if Oh hmm one more thing okay yeah hmm
check out yamimash his channel
it's inscription you're welcome bye
come back here
coming up
Oh
but don't even try to go for the cave oh
the mountain